[Music]
and Netflix for cars news like Carmack's
show me the CARFAX Oh like in the TVs in
the car you can start streaming okay
submitted by hardwood or carpet hardwood
floor living space and then carpet from
my bed that's me that's me I love that
oh I got that
I like hardwood that's my house cuz
carpet feels cozy but then you wake up
the main space is you gotta build a
cleaning easier yeah my carpets just dog
hair yeah so you can now get a Netflix
like monthly subscription for cars most
of you ran out whatever cars you want oh
like every week you got a different car
like Toro like that one website when you
rent it or not Toro but yeah yeah so
there's these services that allow you to
have monthly subscriptions and then you
can switch out your car whenever you
want like Ford has one it's interesting
it's like a lease but not this
particular I don't think I would do it
you're expensive too well no I just
don't like so people have their odors on
their loneliness like that I can't
yeah I mean you have to stay within the
brand well it depends which which one
you sign up with so for example for the
Ford one them yet you have to because I
like different cars and different brands
different yeah they also have they also
have like super fancy like [ __ ]
millionaire people can subscribe to this
kind of services they also have those
too so you can get like a helicopter and
then a yacht no you can get like really
expensive carpet fries yeah I end up
putting stuff in my cars and I only
transfer one stock to another car and it
transfer again you know yeah what do you
carry in your car
I don't know me I don't have anything
better turns a mess I better [ __ ]
you see shoes and clothing like laughing
each door which I'm totally nice oh yeah
you have a what from each one nice and
each door that's pretty smart I always
have a knife - yeah I need a knife can
you give me a knife yup done but it's
also good for like oh you [ __ ] fall
in a lake yeah and you need a pepper dam
yeah yeah I have like a bunch of board
games Wow you never invite us over to
play board game because I don't really
care much for you guys I love you I love
you the most out of everyone I'm taking
you off of Tyga's the Packers will ya
Tigers will I'm gonna give anything ever
happened to you guys I'd kill everyone
and then myself who didn't it be your
will look at that no tech as well
because of whoever's gonna take you away
you see don't kill every one of us and
then you'll kill yourself I said if
anyone [ __ ] with you guys all everyone
than myself no cuz I was just imagining
like TIFF got hurt and in your life what
was what service is it cold so there's
this one that they're mentioning called
canvas and so like that one is pretty
depressing what is it how much is it a
month clutch cuz it sounds kind of fun
actually
it does I'm nothing now wait [ __ ] um
like afford to rent like a Ford Fusion
and then a [ __ ] like Taurus a neo geo
Geodude no that's a game no yeah geo is
the car yeah well they don't metro did
you Metro give you a cheap [ __ ] pizza
we [ __ ] gamer I know right yeah they
also so they're mentoring
they're mentioning that they offers a
variety of types of cars or even like
once least kind of cars so I'm not
really like pre
or anything then I feel like this I
would read all kinds of [ __ ] a [ __ ]
school bus a semi-truck Oh rather than
my truck
[ __ ] yeah you know fun not be my house
and then the next thing I rent like the
smallest convertible like a [ __ ]
Miata or something you got a [ __ ]
Porsche that was small as [ __ ] smaller
than a Porsche that what happened did a
Mini Cooper
those Chinese [ __ ] taking forever
like three months oh your trunk get your
big-ass [ __ ] monster truck that'd be
really fun though
cuz if I could just pay like I don't
know how much it is but like I don't
know like 500 bucks a month or ya know
regular car payment but you get to have
new cars that's like well it depends
which one yeah it's 500 I can write out
like a [ __ ] ball masks are a big dope
the other I've driving limit so for
example there's like five hundred miles
a month or you can pay extra to have
like unlimited miles a month different
than what you want anybody drive 500
NASA I don't I don't know anywhere my
house three years I've only done like
yeah $14 canvas it's only limited to San
Francisco in LA that's time I want to
check the subject I'm just I'm curious I
just want to see what I'm so stoked that
I live in this like and this time yeah I
[ __ ] love like the technology and
everything at my [ __ ] I love it city
to that things actually happened in like
if you're in the middle of like
Wisconsin yeah can we get the [ __ ] you
know I love it though I love that too
but then I kind of get jealous is like
my kids and stuff cuz I'm like Danny
you're gonna have way better
like Isaac you don't understand how
lucky you are when you're grown up
you're gonna have so like the stuff is
everybody not jealous though because
like we're when we were growing up we
saw the difference like we saw the no
computer time the very limited Internet
like so now we appreciate it right but
with our kids they're not it's just
that's just a matter of they're not
getting Isaac ready for singularity cuz
I'll be sitting them down like look
robots are gonna [ __ ] take over by
the time you're an adult you need to
learn right now how to code that [ __ ]
and [ __ ] can you talk to Tiger then I
will I'll make sure if you guys missed
that point I'll [ __ ] do it cuz I'll
be like you color Muay Thai Jiu Jitsu
it don't matter man robots you got to
figure out how to turn them off just
spray them with water oh yeah coding
classes he doesn't like it Oh has what
classes what else what else kind of [ __ ]
future I can't believe you're gonna have
internet access like to travel right
that he's traveled so much she's not a
good one though because I am jealous of
the future traveling like a bear yeah
it's gonna be so much quicker they're
gonna have those Rockets we're doing it
anywhere in the planet got tube trained
like that Bank toy treasure yeah
Elementary School's yelling at kids I do
get future jealous of me being a grandpa
and thinking [ __ ] these [ __ ]
can't have immortality while they're
young can you imagine it's like back in
my day we have to take airplanes like a
[ __ ] loser you know like this is
gonna be so different now I know back in
my dad to drive my own car
I'd actually learned how to drive my car
I bet you there's a lot of grandpa's
that our future jealous of our fate
a generation or present jealous because
they're all like man look at all these
girls now they're ready to [ __ ] that's
you you always say you're like when I
was going to school they were all
jealous jealous not my dad my dad's not
future jealous at all cuz he was like
back in my day at least we knew for a
DIYer girl like you guys don't even know
you guys are not even a problem jealous
because [ __ ] kids these days have
Google and we had Encyclopedia
Britannica though we have all but there
was like two pages like we didn't have
any information yeah like their research
it's so much easier now but I like that
cuz I could use as an excuse so back to
my third grade I got to go look
something up I'm like I have to go to
that volume right and the teachers a
hurry I'm looking oh my god might be
researching right now but the nowadays
it's like it's a quick second yeah and
you can't you can't waste time anymore
they can cheat so much easier hi my
friend just [ __ ] sit next to me
mm-hmm shout out to Jackie I love you
man I'll never forget him oh that's a
guy always like how did you guys cheat
you know [ __ ] yeah I hold life no I had
like I had paper like I would write it
pre write it on the desk or I had a
little sheet and I would keep it in
between my legs so they can't tell you
to like open
right right provider on the inside at
label if you slowly peel it off and you
just have your bottle of water it's
kinda like oh no they're reflection on
the inside yeah yeah or the inside of a
pen I write on the bottom of shoes no
they like smartwatches and you sit there
and scroll no lucky so jealous very
empathic present too late now contact
lenses that projectors I probably have I
can cost one time I cheated really bad
where I like the chapter that I needed a
cheat on I read it like 10 times so that
it really seemed like I knew that
information and then anyone could ask me
any question I knew everything about
that chocolate my classmates were so
[ __ ] stupid he would try to cheat
during an open book test oh my god like
we're like I was like the answers just
in bold man you got to look for it and
he's on some peeps I'm like what the
[ __ ] dude it's open book just you read
it I'll just see what you did it's not
cheating because it didn't it's just
laziness yeah yeah the teachers were
smart though and they would give us
those tests that like in an index card
you can write whatever you want yeah
however yeah your Chi Chi I'm like
that's [ __ ] brilliant cuz as soon as
you're writing a already River fellows
my algebra or geometry no well at one of
those where you have to have the
equations hmm so I [ __ ] learn how to
microscopically write that [ __ ] cuz we
had one card yeah I try to get as many
formulas as I can yeah it'll be smallest
book oh man I wish I could go back in
time and then see all the students do
that [ __ ] right just to see how stupid
we work is we were not hiding it well at
all but we thought we weren't did you
guys tape it to what you could tape the
index card cuz the lead like rubs
if you write this long
I use a fine point pen yeah yeah yeah
the Asian pen yes the American pens
don't have they're small like a
needlepoint pen yeah dan I cheated so
much in high school I didn't I just
didn't do my work Thank You tilling
whatever senior year to realize that the
answers are all in the book when you
spend you didn't realize that the books
is what taught you I just thought you
read the book and then when they give
you a test you have to develop your idea
based off of the book
[Music]
[Music]